a test of endurance for the runners a
test of nerve for the organizers Doha's
air-cooled Khalifa stadium isn't an
option for the road races and despite a
midnight start time high humidity
contributed to more than a third of the
field failing to finish in last week's
women's marathon conditions were kinder
for the men's race with humidity below
50% higher humidity what happens is it
doesn't allow the body to cool so our
mechanism sweating and the evaporation
of sweat off the body is your cooling
mechanism skin is your largest organ of
your body so the ability to cool and
evaporate is important higher humidity
you're not evaporating that sweat off
your body more than 50 competitors of
these championships have volunteered to
consume electronic capsules which
contain thermometers and transmitters to
keep a track on their core temperature
during events there are also infrared
cameras being used during competition to
measure the athletes skin temperature
again these are single users it's the
sort of information performance experts
can use to better prepare athletes for
future races with heat and humidity set
to be a big factor at next year's Tokyo
Olympics months before these
Championships runners were receiving
guidance on what to expect in Doha if
you're an elite athlete considering the
medical setting we have here and if you
have if you have previously been through
acclimatization I would say yes
definitely is safe because we have also
a novice scale and over equipped medical
staff and medical planned in this
marathon 18 runners failed to finish
from a field of 73 out in front there
was a sprint finish to the line as
Ethiopia's lilee siddhis Issa won gold
these conditions are not going to
produce personal bests and world records
I mean again you've got to be very well
trained but you know again it's part of
the sport there's part of what we're
facing in endurance events and indoors
medicine around the world so it's part
of the new norm conditions appear to
suit DC sir he won in his best time of
the season Andy Richardson al Jazeera
Doha